la climatisation nous rafraîchit tel
autant qu'on le pense il y a deux mille
ans les romains faisait circuler de
l'eau dans les murs des maisons pour les
refroidir
au début du 20e siècle on fuyait la
chaleur des grandes villes américaines
en allant au cinéma comme les endroits
publics climatisés
de nos jours il suffit de tourner un
bouton pour rafraîchir sa maison sa
voiture en quelques minutes mais cette
précieuse fraîcheur produits en réalité
beaucoup de chaleur il faut en effet
brûlé chaque année des millions de
tonnes de pétrole de gaz et charbon dans
le monde pour produire l'électricité
nécessaire à la climatisation au canada
un pays pourtant nordiques plus de 50%
des ménages possèdent un climatiseur
notre consommation d'énergie pour la
climatisation a bondi de + 44% en 25 ans
et on ne parle pas ici des commerces et
des édifices à bureaux aux états-unis
grands champions de la climatisation
lutte 87 % des foyers en possèdent un
mais les états unis sont talonnés de
près par la chine l'inde ou l'indonésie
ou les ventes de climatiseurs explose à
ce rythme la demande énergétique
mondiale pour la climatisation sera
multiplié par dix d'ici 2050 prévoient
les experts
et ce n'est pas tout les climatiseurs
contiennent aussi des gaz réfrigérants
les hcfc qui attaquent la couche d'ozone
et qui possède un pouvoir défaite certes
plusieurs milliers de fois supérieur à
celui du co2 finalement plus on dépense
d'énergie à se rafraîchir aujourd'hui et
plus il fera chaud demain